good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
thanks so much for coming to MIT for
this this symposium and announcement
from the FCC broadband initiative my
name is Chris csikszentmihalyi on behalf
of MIT the MIT Media Lab in the center
for future Civic Media and comparative
Media Studies which is a lot of
organizations we want to so there's a
lot of welcome out to you for thanks for
coming we were approached by the FCC to
host this and felt it was an important
part of our service to promote a public
dialogue on this broadband plan because
it really is a historic moment for
almost all of the whole of this nation's
history it's been considered the role of
the US government to proactively ensure
a free and diverse press and source of
information for communities one of the
ways this occurred was through strong
discounts postage discounts for
magazines and newspapers where the
postal policies gave tremendous
subsidies to any newspaper magazine or
periodical that could inform a citizen
and improve a democracy none other than
George Washington work to provide
massive subsidies to mailed newspapers
subsidies that largely benefited the
smaller publications they couldn't reach
economies of scales or negotiate special
bargains Washington wasn't able to give
the one hundred percent subsidies that
he thought were necessary it's really
easy to be dismissive of the postal
service at this point at your own peril
but but at that point that was the
medium for getting information to people
but nonetheless newspaper shipman was so
cheap that citizens would often buy a
newspaper write a letter to their mom
and the margins between the headlines
then folded back up and send it because
it was so much cheaper than sending an
envelope so you know and I love that
because there's this great moment in
which personal and political news are
traveling together in the same medium in
the second decade of the 20th century
communities in the northern Midwest
started experimenting with a process of
rural electrification developing
electrical connections for mode farms by
the 1930s the REA the rural electrical
administration
was formed in by an act of congress and
within five years they'd doubled the
number of farms that had access to the
point where now we're talking about
ninety-eight percent of rural
communities and farms in the US have
electricity and if you fuse those two
remarkably successful examples of smart
government you get to the point where
we're at now we're through electronic
medium through a wired or a fiber
service much of the news that we get and
the important information communications
that we have in the United States are
traveling so today the Pew Charitable
Trust released a report titled
understanding the participatory news
consumer which finds that for the first
time according to their study American
consumers get more information online
than they do from printed media now the
unfortunate problem there is that most
of the news that's being generated the
kind of complex journalism long-term
investigation that we rely on for
democracy most of that is still being
generated by those news organizations so
there's a little bit of a schism there
and kind of a crisis brewing where the
organizations that are gathering much of
the important use are really
hemorrhaging their sources of income and
you know but they're still doing it or
at least last night when I checked they
were still doing it let's just hope they
are today so what we're witnessing is a
monumental transformation and and a
really critical thing for communities to
be part of that discourse to be on the
information matrix but our broadband
access rates are kind of closer to those
of wired rural farms in the 1920s they
hover between somewhere around sixty
sixty-five percent twelve percent of
that the last I read was through
borrowed Wi-Fi my neighbors and 54 Adams
Street for instance but the
unfortunately the costs and even the
speed connection speeds our fire far
higher than they need to be in the US is
lagging many many many other nations in
terms of speed and availability so we're
about to hear from the FCC regarding
their report to Congress on how to spend
the 7.2
million dollars set aside for ensuring
that every American has access to
high-quality broadband the point of this
event is to hear from the FCC which has
already worked quite a bit and already
taken a lot of public comment so we're
not really focusing this so much on on a
dialogue or public comment because
they've had many many public hearings
already on but we are going to bring two
panels of excellent people together
afterwards to concentrate on two subject
first interactions between citizens and
governments that are enabled by online
access and how those interactions might
be better made through ubiquitous
broadband and second the role of public
media in this changing landscape I hope
that both panels will pay special
attention to issues the digital divide
as the FCC didn't its plan this report
is only the first step of the process
though as community leaders collectives
coops individuals educational
institutions and businesses need to work
to ensure that as we did with
electricity and free press before that
we helped government to help our
communities to be more vital prosperous
and democratic so let me then introduce
our first speaker Eugene Wang who was
appointed secretary of Technology the
state of Virginia at the age of I think
14 was it later he became senior policy
adviser to henry paulson but he read the
writing on the wall and moved to the FCC
where he is director of government
operations for the Federal Communication
Commission's National Broadband task
force and with someone with a long last
name I really appreciate that title so
please join me in welcoming Eugene
Chris thank you for that very kind
introduction it's wonderful to be here
at MIT and my deep appreciation to MIT
for serving as our hosts today mit has
produced a great number of many great
graduates and not least which is a
member of my team Michelle Doshi who's
in the second row right over here to
vishal thank you for your hard work on
the National Broadband Plan to MIT thank
you for letting him graduate now in all
seriousness MIT in the center for future
Civic Media is a leader in the area that
my remarks will address today the area
of civic engagement you are truly a
leader in the world in innovation at the
intersection of Technology and civic
engagement with an incredible number of
groundbreaking projects going on here
from news flow which maps real-time news
reporting to lost in Boston a web tool
that cities can use to engage citizens
and improvement projects there is
tremendous innovation occurring here for
the team members who have worked on the
civic engagement section of the National
Broadband Plan this has been a long
journey many hours of work and many
sleep-deprived days and nights will have
been spent on the plan a plan that when
it is released in about two weeks will
inspire a vision for broad bands future
in America the team has worked very hard
to get to this point and before I lay
out our proposed recommendations I'd
like to take a minute to explain how we
got here the path to a national
broadband plan began over a year ago
with Congress Congress tasked the FCC
with developing a national broadband
plan as part of the Recovery Act and the
quote directly from the Recovery Act the
ambitious goal of the plan is to ensure
that every American has quote access to
broadband capability unquote Congress
mandated that the plan address for
questions first how will broadband
infrastructure be deployed throughout
the United States this question is
answered through an analysis of the most
efficient
and effective means to pull it to deploy
broadband either via wired wireless or
satellite infrastructure to ensure that
all people the United States have access
to broadband second how will you ensure
adoption of broadband services in the
United States this question is led to a
detailed strategy for adoption of
broadband services including achieving
affordable access to broadband services
as well as maximum utilization of
broadband infrastructure and service by
the public third what is the status of
broadband deployment in the United
States and forth how will Americans use
broadband services in the future to
address this question we've looked at
how broadband will address specific
national priorities including government
performance and civic engagement Public
Safety and Homeland Security community
development health care and health IT
energy independence and efficiency
education workforce training private
sector investment entrepreneurial
activity job creation and economic
growth so how do we develop answers to
each of these four questions now to
develop the National Broadband Plan
Blair live in our director assembled a
task force of more than 50 individuals
from backgrounds including government
employees individuals from the private
sector technologists consultants venture
capitalists MBAs PhDs and yes even a few
lawyers but don't blame me I'm an
electrical engineer and a technologist
not a lawyer overall we've described the
work we've undertaken since last summer
as a three act play in june and july of
last year we began with the prologue
outlining the process and vision serving
as the foundation for the plan act one
which started in august and went through
december represented our fact-gathering
stage act to stretch into january and
focused on analyzing the facts that had
been collected and an act three our
final act the task force is developing
our recommendations prior to the release
of the plan in just a few short weeks
we're doing our best to ensure that the
plan is neither a tragedy nor a comedy
but in all seriousness during this
process the FCC has worked hard to
practice what we preach in terms of
civic engagement one of the major goals
for the process of developing the
national broadband plan is to ensure
that we are a transparent inclusive and
participatory to that end I'm proud to
say that this has been the most open and
transparent data driven process in the
FCC's history we've attempted to
practice what we preach by seeking
public input in a variety of ways we've
held more than 35 public workshops with
well over 350 panelists on the different
topics that the plan will address these
workshops have generated tremendous
interest with more than 1,000 people
attending in person more than 5000
people participating online every one of
the workshops we've held has been
streamed online and individuals have
been able to participate from as far
away as America Samoa and Sweden we've
also had a record number of public
notices for everyone here that isn't
steeped in the minutia of how the FCC
goes about its work a public notice is
the way the government formally asks for
public comment or input on an issue we
release 30 public notices and in return
we amassed a significant volume of
public comments that represents a public
record of over 20,000 individual
responses that in total exceed over
70,000 pages the FCC has also made
extensive use of social media and
crowdsourcing tools during this process
the FCC launched a presence on Facebook
Twitter and other social media sites and
since launching on Twitter last fall
we've asked more than 330,000 Twitter
followers making us the third highest of
any government agency behind only the
White House and the CDC if government
Twitter followers were an Olympic sport
we would have awarded been awarded a
bronze medal a significant
accomplishment since the gold medal went
to the president and the silver medal
went to swine flu we've also launched a
blog where the chairman and members of
the task force have posted updates and
have asked
feedback the blog located at ww Bri been
gud forty blog posts and 340 comments in
the first month after we launched it now
our blogging has only increased since
the first month of launch with 175 total
posts and more than 11,000 thousand
comments we will also use IdeaScale to
crowdsource ideas for the plan the
result more than 450 ideas many of which
are in the plan these ideas generated
more than 7,500 comments and over 37,000
votes now after all of this data
collection we came to what may seem like
an obvious conclusion civic engagement
is the lifeblood of our democracy while
this might sound cliched I don't believe
that it is democracy at its core is
about self governance at the most basic
level this requires an informed and
engaged citizenry to participate in
societies institutions engage their
government and hold it accountable
democracy requires an informed and
engaged citizens citizenry in order to
validate the actions of government so
that it reflects the will of the people
in short civic engagement is a very big
deal so that's civic engagement but what
about broadband what does broadband have
to do with civic engagement we came to
the conclusion that broadband has the
potential to transform civic engagement
in two principal ways first broadband
can strengthen the reach and relevance
of mediated and unmediated information
for our society a healthy democracy
requires an informed citizenry and
broadband can change the way that people
engage this information this is true for
mediated information such as public
media and this is also true for
unmediated information such as the data
the government provides citizens second
broadband can enable citizens to engage
in their democracy through a variety of
broadband enable tools that will make
our democracy more participant
whirring and more representative
broadband enabled technologies have
already revolutionized the way citizens
interact with each other in the private
sector companies such as YouTube enable
the distribution of user-generated
content over the internet YouTube now
supports more than 120 million viewers
watching more than 10 billion videos
monthly and more than eighty percent of
u.s. adults who are online use social
media at least once a month and half of
them participate in social media social
networks such as Facebook today
twenty-six percent of Americans are
involved in a civic or political group
and more than half of them use digital
tools to communicate with other group
members given this context our proposed
recommendations for the National
Broadband Plan fall into five areas
first we looked at ways to build a more
open and transparent government this
principally involves increasing citizens
access to unmediated information and we
think that the federal government has
made good progress in this area recently
but we believe that there is more that
the government can and should do the
executive branch's data.gov initiative
is one example data.gov is a web portal
that offers an index of data generated
by government agencies in
machine-readable format launched last
May data.gov has been a tremendous
success receiving more than 47 million
visits in the first seven months this
initiative demonstrates that while there
is great demand for government to be a
wholesaler of data it's still not enough
data clev includes only a small amount
of federal government data and we
believe that all data and information
that the government treats is public
should be made available online in
machine-readable formats and although
daddy gov applies to the executive
branch we believe that similar
initiatives should also extend to both
Congress and the Judiciary moreover for
data that is actionable or otherwise
time sensitive in nature the executive
branch should provide individuals with a
single web-based interface to manage
email alerts
other electronic communications from the
federal government in addition to making
more data available to the public we
believe that the primary legal documents
of the federal government should be made
free and publicly available online while
this might seem obvious to some this is
not current practice for example in the
federal judicial system the public
access to court electronic records
system or casar still charges for access
to federal district appellate and
bankruptcy court records the US federal
courts themselves pay private
contractors a hundred and fifty million
dollars annually for electronic access
to judicial documents we believe that
these types of barriers inhibit a
principle of democracy that every person
who is subject to the laws of this
nation should have free access to those
laws online we also believe that the
knight Commission had it right when
expressed the principle that the
public's business should be done in
public toward that end government
meetings public hearings and town hall
meetings should also be streamed online
these events should also offer closed
captioning services to increase
accessibility for persons with
disabilities and should also allow
people to ask questions online where
feasible our second area of focus has
been public media while broadband can
enable the release of more unmediated
information it can also provide greater
access to mediated information through
media and journalism public media has
historically provided invaluable
educational news and other media content
looking into the future this could not
be more important at a time when many of
our journalism and media institutions
are under severe stress today newspapers
are closing local TV news stations are
laying off reporters and state houses
and other institutions are drawing fewer
and fewer journalists to cover the news
just as communities depend on
individuals to create
and maintain communities individuals
need trusted intermediaries to connect
them with relevant accurate information
in response to this trend public media
must continue to play a critical role in
the development of a healthy and
thriving media ecosystem by providing
individuals with information developing
public debate and conversations in
building cohesion and participation in
our communities but a Public Media's
future is to be successful as its past
it must transition from a 20th century
broadcast based model to a 21st century
broadband based model today public media
is at a crossroads it is predominantly
structured around broadcast based
communications both legally and in
practice this presents a clear challenge
as we enter the digital age public media
must continue to expand beyond its
original broadcast based mission to form
the core of a broader new public media
network that better serves the new
multi-platform information needs of the
future this is no small challenge yet
I'm optimistic about the future of
public media because it has already
begun this transition and is showing
great results let me give you a few
examples across the Charles right here
in Boston WGBH developed the teachers
domain a free collection of more than
2,000 digital resources covering diverse
content for students and teachers last
year was the 40th anniversary of sesame
street and just a few months ago pbl PBS
launched the PBS kids preschool video
player with more than 87 million streams
of educational content being delivered
in just the first month we also have
great examples in public radio NPR
launched a tremendously successful API
and apps using this API our content to
access content have been developed for
the iphone and android and NPR podcasts
are being downloaded more than 15
million times a month so we believe that
the future of public media is bright but
it also faces challenges to the extent
that government can help to facilitate a
digital transition
and mitigate these challenges we believe
it should do so one of these challenges
is the Copyright Act Congress passed
special copyright exemptions for public
broadcasting in the 20th century but
these provisions no longer fulfill their
original purpose for example current
licensing practices inhibit public
broadcaster's from producing and
distributing the highest quality digital
programming these exemptions should be
updated to facilitate the distribution
of the highest quality programming on
21st century digital platforms finally
during this process we began to ask
ourselves what a national digital
archive for the 21st century must look
like broadband holds great potential for
increasing people's access to historical
materials and we believe that the
government should get the ball rolling
in this area by creating video gov a new
video platform for the federal
government's digital public video
content video gov should be modeled
after data gov and the federal
government should convene a group
comprised of federal agencies the
National Archives and the library of
congress to develop this platform we
believe that video gov has the potential
to be a huge success but we think it
should be only one part of a larger
national federated archive that would
include public media and maybe even
commercial media as well today these
institutions sit on a wealth of America
civic DNA in the form of historic TV
news content that goes back more than 50
years millions of hours of historic news
content that represents America's daily
life this archival content could provide
tremendous educational opportunities for
generations of students and could
revolutionize how we access our own
history we believe that this is a
tremendous opportunity but we realize
that this is not without its challenges
for example public television has
attempted to launch such digital video
archive but has run into difficulties
obtaining the rights clearances that it
needs to MIT
this issue Congress should consider
amending the Copyright Act to enable
public and broadcast media to more
easily contribute their archival content
to a digital National Archive to help
this turn this vision into a reality
digital archives hold tremendous
potential to transform the way the
American people learn about themselves
their communities and their history we
can enable this transformation by
removing the barriers that inhibit the
development of a new ecosystem
surrounding public media now in addition
to increasing the Americans people
access to mediated than an unmediated
information in digital formats broadband
can also improve the quality and number
of points at which the American people
can access their government we've been
focusing on three specific areas to this
effect social media innovation and
government and digital democracy social
media has been our third area of focus
by most standards social media is not
new many Americans use tools such as
Facebook and Twitter in their daily
lives on a regular basis the FCC
recently released a study of broadband
adoption use in America showing that
fifty-five percent of broadband users
also use social networking sites
focusing on individuals aged 18 point 18
to 29 much like individuals here at MIT
this number skyrockets to eighty-five
percent and these numbers are likely to
grow even further in the coming years
unfortunately government has not
integrated these tools across the board
the same way that the private sector has
we believe that government must adopt
these tools to provide opportunities for
citizens to engage using the same
communications mechanisms that they use
in their daily lives furthermore we
believe that government should view
social media technologies not as pilot
projects or add-ons but as core to its
mission government should use a variety
of new media tools from those primarily
used to communicate to though those that
enable more intensive participation and
that specialize in co-production and co
governance
while the success integrating of these
integrating these tools in the
government has been uneven we believe
that there is reason for optimism as I
mentioned earlier the FCC has integrated
the use of Twitter Facebook IdeaScale
and other tools into the fabric of the
agency in addition the CDC has had great
success in this area using social media
platforms to provide access to credible
science-based health information the
CDC's use of social media has been
instrumental in enabling them to get
reliable information about the h1n1
virus to the public quickly between
april and december of last year the cdc
had more than 2.6 million downloads of
h1n1 podcasts more than more than 3
million views of h1n1 related YouTube
videos more than 37 million views of
h1n1 related media feeds social media is
also giving rise to citizen to citizen
democracy diplomacy these tools are
connecting individuals across nations
and regions as one example the State
Department recently launched its virtual
student foreign service enabling college
students to become quote-unquote dorm
room diplomats these students are then
matched with embassies and students in
other countries to build transnational
relationships and cultural understanding
through digital citizen to citizen
diplomacy in short government is
certainly making progress but these
examples are the exception rather than
the rule recognizing the promise that
social media holds our federal
government should accelerate the
adoption of social media technologies
across all agencies the fourth area that
we've been focused on in civic
engagement involves the innovation that
occurs at the nexus of broadband and
civic engagement beyond communicating
with individuals broadband provides an
opportunity to engage citizens in more
direct collaboration with their
government in ways that lead to greater
innovation we all know that many of the
best ideas come from outside of
government to take advantage of these
ideas we should create avenues for more
citizens to help spur innovation
within the government government is just
beginning to think about these types of
issues as one example the White House
has used participatory tools the open
government initiative to begin changing
the nature of participatory governance
specifically the White House has engaged
citizens and development of this
initiative through public brainstorming
blogs a wiki and a collaborative
drafting tool but we believe that
government can and should do more in
this area an open platforms initiative
throughout our government has the
potential to leverage digital platforms
to engage and draw on the expertise of
citizens in the private sector from peer
review and open problem-solving
platforms to open grant-making platforms
we believe that these platforms can both
engage citizen experts and improve
government performance bringing
individuals with a proven record of
innovation into government service has
the ability to bring new ideas and
perspectives to some of the challenges
that government faces an innovation
Fellows Program could place private
sector experts and innovators throughout
the federal government on one-year
fellowships and an innovation Corps
could serve as a think tank for
technologists from inside and outside
government to help design digital
platforms and applications for all
levels of government last but certainly
not least you can't talk about the
future of civic engagement without
talking about the future of our
democratic processes more Americans
engage in democratic elections than just
about any other civic act by bringing
the elections process into the digital
age government can promote greater civic
participation and increase the
efficiency of the process providing
broadband to more Americans provides an
important opportunity to fix the
problems in the existing process
starting with voter registration the
current paper-based system for
registration of voters can include
multiple cumbersome steps from
collecting information on paper forms to
manually entering handwritten data onto
voter lists one recent study estimates
that though
registration problems resulted in more
than 2 million voters being unable to
vote in the 2008 general election the
challenges are even more difficult for
members of the military serving overseas
these individuals are more than twice as
likely to face registration problems as
the general public while these
challenges are great several states have
already taken steps to modernize the
voter registration process as examples
Arizona Kansas and Washington state
already permit citizens to complete and
submit voter registration applications
online in addition to allowing for
online voter registration common
standards would assist in making voter
records portable to increase accuracy
improve the efficiency in the process
and decrease costs several states have
already begun moving forward with
standards to facilitate data exchange
across state borders while this process
is encouraging we need a more
comprehensive effort to modernize the
process across all 50 states for
elections and all levels we believe that
federal state and local stakeholders
should work together to modernize the
elections process by addressing these
and other concerns finally as mentioned
earlier our military men and women
serving overseas face very real
challenges when they are trying to vote
one survey showed that more than half of
the military serving overseas who tried
to vote weren't able to do so because
their ballots were late or didn't arrive
at all and a survey of seven states show
that an average of more than twenty-five
percent of military and overseas ballots
were returned as undeliverable lost or
rejected in the two thousand eight
election we all agree that the
government has a moral obligation to
ensure that those military men and women
protecting us from harm's way are able
to vote because no one should have to
give up the right to vote as a condition
serving their country the federal
government has recently taken steps to
begin addressing this problem the millet
the military and overseas voter
empowerment act recently passed by
requires that starting with the 2010
elections states must establish
procedures to allow military and
overseas voters to request an absentee
ballot applications electronically for
federal elections this is an important
step in the right direction states are
making some progress on this issue as
well in two thousand eight Arizona
launched a web-based voting system that
allows the military and overseas
citizens to vote online with completed
ballots uploaded directly to the
Secretary of State's website there are
their exciting initiatives happening at
the intersection of broadband and
democratic processes and we need to
ensure that this progress continues to
this end the Department of Defense
should be tasked with the development of
a secure internet based pilot project
that enables members of the military
serving overseas to vote online DoD has
looked into this in the past and there
are clearly security and privacy
concerns that must be addressed but we
believe that as long as our military men
and women are serving overseas and
unable to vote we must continue working
to do everything we can to address the
serious problem the proposed
recommendations that I've presented to
you today represent not an end but a
beginning a beginning of a new era in
civic engagement in America in five
distinct areas open and transparent
government public media social media
engaging citizens and government
innovation and modernizing our
democratic processes we believe that
broadband has the potential to transform
civic engagement but this transformation
will not occur on its own it will take a
commitment from all of us our government
our elected leaders in the public at
large to renew our democracy in a
broadband enabled 21st century we look
forward to this challenge thank you very
much
you